Tom Brady knows all about winning
championships he has four Super Bowl
rings within Patriots but the most
important ring he has is the one that
keeps him connected to the world's top
supermodel what you doing there not
liking that left-hand jewelry that's
what we're talking about absolutely you
know Tom gave me a glimpse inside his
and yourself fun family like I love this
picture that you had gizelle posted on
Father's Day of you guys just playing in
the staff those two clans will wear me
out
owned by they owned by life oh my god
yeah three-year-old Vivian has him
wrapped around her little finger you
cannot say no to anything you know she
just yeah whatever she tells are dead
that's what I do so it's two sons Jack
and Ben are his two little mini means
last weekend Jack showed he's got skills
check out the dad who knows that they'll
play sports if they do I think it's
great because I can really help them out
but if they don't you know that son you
know that's up to them Tom's also a huge
celebrity away from the football field
with a supermodel wife who coaches him
with those public appearances gizelle
say okay baby let me give you a lesson
before you go out and do this do you get
lessons at home I would say instruction
not necessarily lessons but I don't she
definitely she definitely helps me out
and you probably heard about the Brady
Bunch and diet 80% vegetables but no
tomatoes eggplant or mushrooms and Tom's
not a big fan of fruits
never had a strawberry my life you
imagine that hold on I don't know you've
never see that's not obviously you know
people could eat those and enjoy him but
I can I don't know I don't know I think
it's something growing up